with oil prices tumbling stock prices
falling in bonds rising the word
recession is getting tossed around quite
a bit here are three charts that support
the idea that the u.s. may be entering a
downturn first you've got corporate
profits earnings are set to drop for a
third straight quarter on a share
weighted basis profits in the sp500 are
expected to have dropped by more than
seven percent last quarter that is the
blue bar at the far right-hand side now
the main drags on earnings the slumping
crude prices and the dollars strength
then you've got manufacturing the
already slowing sector closed out 2015
with a thud going down the isn
manufacturing slipped below 50
indicating contraction in November and
December and we're seeing services the
orange lines start to take a little bit
of a leg down as well and finally
another cause for concern if you believe
that credit always leads the plunge in
oil blew out spreads and energy
high-yield credit and soon other
high-yield sectors saw similar widening
now it's infected investment-grade debt
the premium that investors demand to be
paid over holding Treasuries is now
approaching levels seen in the last two
recessions 2001 2007